. In a move of total desperation, Donald Trump
has announced that he is now going to consider
pardoning Edward Snowden in a completely obvious
gambit to maybe try to take control of the
election and appeal to some voters.
And this is super interesting, partially because
Donald Trump previously called for Edward
Snowden to be executed.
It's also partially interesting because it's
not clear whether this would actually help
Donald Trump.
So let's take it from the top.
Edward Snowden is the former NSA contractor
who's been living in Russia for years to escape
prosecution here in the United States for
leaking classified documents that exposed
that the NSA and the government, other government
agencies were doing this mass bulk surveillance.
Trump was asked about Edward Snowden over
the weekend, and here's what he had to say.
You want to give Edward Snowden a pardon and
bring him back?
You suggest, well, I'm the right guy.
I mean, I'm not that aware of the Snowden
situation, but I want to start looking at
it.
There are many, many people it seems to be
a split decision, and many people think that
he should be somehow treated differently and
other people think he did very bad things.
And I'm going to take a very good look at
it.
OK.
I mean, I I've I've seen people that are very
conservative and very liberal, and they agree
on the same issue.
They agree both ways.
I'm going to take a look at that very strongly.
Edward Snowden.
Yep, less so in Trump's mealy mouth and confused
way.
He's saying, yeah, he's going to look at pardoning
Edward Snowden.
Now, remember that Donald Trump previously
said in a tweet, quote, Snowden is a spy who
should be executed.
But if it and he could reveal Obama's records,
I might become a major fan.
Trump tweeted about Edward Snowden's.
Snowden is a traitor and a disgrace.
Make no mistake, he is no hero.
In fact, he is a coward who should come back
and face justice.
Trump tweeted, Snowden is a liar and a fraud.
Trump tweeted, Like it or not, Edward Snowden
is a spy and should be tried as a spy.
He is still an invaluable information and
damaged us with other nations.
Trump a second time with the execution of
Snowden tweeting Snowden is a spy who has
caused great damage to the U.S.
A spy in the old days when our country was
respected and strong would be executed.
Trump tweeted hilariously message to Edward
Snowden.
You're banned from Miss Universe unless you
want me to take you back home to face justice
so I could go on.
Trump has 45 tweets about some Snowden.
But the point is, Trump could not have been
more against Snowden for a year after year
after year until now.
And to be clear, the problem here is not that
Trump might change his mind.
Changing one's mind is good.
You learn something new, you reevaluate your
position and your belief might be modified.
That's a beautiful thing.
We should applaud that rather than ridicule
it.
The issue here is Trump hasn't learned anything
other than maybe pardoning Snowden would help
me in November.
Trump says in his answer, I don't know much
about him, but I'm going to look at a pardon.
Trump hasn't become informed about Snowden
and now thinks maybe we pardon him.
Trump hasn't suddenly come out against the
surveillance that Snowden exposed.
It's merely Trump thinking, could this helped
me in November?
Maybe it could.
He barely has an idea who Edward Snowden is
or what he did.
Unless Putin has been talking to him about
it, which would be another situation altogether.
So what Trump means by I'm going to take a
look at it is I'm going to think about whether
it might win me some votes in November.
That's absolutely all
that
this is.